I talked to a friend of mine I used to
work with for a number of years at one
of my aerospace companies and he went
out on his own and he started a
maintenance business so residential
he'll come in and do plumbing electrical
lighting and he was charging 65 an hour
and I asked him well how did you come up
with that rate and he said well it just
seems like the fair rate to be charging
everybody I said well do you have a
pricing policy well no I never really
thought about that and so we developed a
pricing policy to in the in that policy
was to charge the highest possible price
while being the best value alternative
and encouraging future business because
we never want to gouge anybody if we're
in a position to do it it needs to be
win-win and we want ongoing business
from from everyone so he moved his price
to 85 an hour for residential and on the
commercial side he was 95 and he moved
it to 145. nobody said a word and he's
so busy he can't keep up with it what
did that do I mean just having that
simple conversation around this is
what's most important as far as the
number the men and these are some
drivers that made a huge impact within
just a couple of months what I love is
such a simple concept but it forces a
lot of difficult decisions to say what
is the one number that we're chasing
down that is the most important thing
for our company and and then what are
the three things underneath that that
make that up and that Clarity really
helped us just make a lot of progress
Simplicity wins elevation we have Mr Lee
Benson in the house he wrote one of my
favorite books of the year no kidding
like I end up seeing so many books and
this one he gave me I was on the plane
coming back home and this changed my
business for the year your most
important number Lee Benson walk on
board man thank you great to be here
looking forward to the conversation
today tell us quickly what is your most
important number
your most important number the book goes
through what I call the Mind methodology
and it's a way of operating an
organization of any size solopreneur
couple of employees 100 employees
thousands of employees to create value
faster and the mind methodology stands
for the acronym most important number in
drivers and every organization has one
number that does two things it says
above all other numbers we're winning or
losing the game it's the measure of
value that the organization is overall
collectively creating and the second
thing it does is it drives the majority
of the right behaviors
so even as a thinking tool if you will
I'm a solopreneur I'm building this
business I'm starting out what really is
most important and then the drivers part
of it these are categories of work that
you know we should be good at leveraging
to improve our most important number
they're Evergreen and that there's no
end to how well we can leverage them to
improve the number but if I'm starting
out with a business and and my most
important number let's just call it
profit there needs to be money left over
that's what this is about
all right so what are the drivers that
can impact that and drivers could be
pricing could be a pricing policy I
talked to uh a friend of mine I used to
work with for a number of years at one
of my aerospace companies and he went
out on his own and he started a
maintenance business so residential
he'll come in and do plumbing electrical
lighting and he was charging 65 an hour
and I asked him well how'd you come up
with that rate
um and he said well it just seems like
the fair rate to be charging everybody I
said well do you have a pricing policy
well no I never really thought about
that and so we developed a pricing
policy to in the and that policy was to
charge the highest possible price while
being the best value alternative and
encouraging future business because we
never want to gouge anybody if we're in
a position to do it it needs to be
win-win and we want ongoing business
from from everyone so he moved his price
to 85 dollars an hour for residential
and on the commercial side he was 90 5
and he moved it to 145 nobody said a
word and he's so busy he can't keep up
with it what did that do I mean just
having that simple conversation around
this is what's most important as far as
the number the men and these are some
drivers that made a huge impact within
just a couple of months so that there's
a there's one example of a solopreneur
getting a a pretty big gain so I met you
through Joe polish and people called Joe
the world's most connected man and I
asked Joe hey what operating system
should I use for my company I feel like
we've grown I had I mean I started this
as a solo entrepreneur we've now got
over 40 people on the team and I feel
like I don't know what I'm doing
especially as we go like layers down
that I could manage maybe 15 people
myself super well but now that we're
adding layers there's no structure and
we're trying to figure it out it's like
I need a I need a an operating system to
follow and I I threw out a couple like
what do you think about this guy what do
you think about this guy everything
about her and Joe Knows everybody and
he's helped a lot of entrepreneurs build
and grow and he said don't talk to any
of those guys
you should talk to Lee pants like okay
who's Lee Benson like Jesus member he's
just sold his company for like 300
million dollars or some crazy number
like that and he's got he's got this
process that we use ourselves and you
should you should see if he can connect
he's here in Phoenix and so send him a
message and so I texted you like that
night and said hey Lee I'm leaving
tomorrow
do you have time to meet up and I think
you're at a hockey game or basketball
game or something uh and you picked me
up the next morning and we went back to
your house which is Beautiful by the way
and then drove me to the airport and he
said hey I've got this I've got this
book that I'm coming out with and this
is the book their most important number
and you gave me the pdf version before
it was even released and like okay don't
share this with anybody because my
Publisher's gonna kill me but like read
it let me know what you think and I read
the whole thing at the airport on the
plane
um it's a it's a super easy read like
this is not a 5 000 page novel and the
pages are easy to dig just especially as
an entrepreneur you want to get through
stuff quickly like I'm the kind of guy
when you read a book and you go five
pages like what did I just read you go
read it back again like this this is an
easy read it changed how I completely
operated my business like on the plane
ride home I'm changing I'm writing my my
wife who's my CEO and then people on the
team okay here's we're making changes
guys here's how we're doing things and
um I I'm even on the back of the book
which is great what did I say here most
entrepreneurs have no structured systems
in place to grow their businesses and
end up feeling overwhelmed staying small
and never reaching their goals your most
important number is is the operations
and Leadership guide that you are never
given it's one of the most powerful
impractical books I've picked up all
year and as a must read for
entrepreneurs
I agree with myself on that one so one
of the biggest things that we changed
was
one even just figuring out what your
most important number is and it it's
such a what I love is such a simple
concept but it forces a lot of difficult
decisions to say what is the one number
that we're chasing down that is the most
important thing for our company and uh
and then what are the three things
underneath that that make that up and
that Clarity
um really helped us just make a lot of
progress and stop overthinking things
and stop getting as an entrepreneurial
organization we still I still I think we
move pretty fast but injecting that
methodology just helped us go so much
faster if somebody's watching us and
trying to figure out okay what's my most
important number how do you guide people
through the process of figuring out what
their most important number is and then
the three drivers underneath that will
make that thing happen yeah the the best
way to do that is to have a conversation
where uh you know again it could be a
solar newer and if you are your team is
going to be advisors mentors contractors
that you work with so you can actually
brainstorm with all of them on this but
if you've got a few team members and and
even sitting there you know by yourself
what would aspirationally winning look
like at the end of the next year and
just list it we snap our fingers with
the end of the year this is what it
looks like this is what we accomplish
and then what would winning look like at
the end of the following year you know
once we built this Foundation going
forward so once you look at that it
makes it pretty easy to see the things
that you need to improve on or the
categories of work you need to improve
on
to you know grow the company make it
successful now from that based on what
we know
what would be that one number that does
the two things that I just talked about
you know above all is or winning or
losing and it will drive the majority of
the right behaviors
so you end up typically in the
for-profit world coming up with some
version of profit if you're a capital
intensive business you have a lot of
inventory Etc it's probably going to be
cash flow because we we all know you can
make a ton of money at the bottom line
and go out of business because you run
out of cash I mean that's possible and
I've seen a number of companies do it
and and so the drivers when you look at
um what what aspirationally winning
looks like over the next one and two
years what do those categories of work
marketing is probably a big one we have
to let people know about what we're
doing but but we don't want to waste
money on marketing and I see a lot of
companies do that by doing sort of a
one-size-fits-all traditional marketing
approach maybe it needs to be trusted
relationship based marketing referral
based marketing that kind of stuff well
we need sales that has to that has to
work you know the pricing policy I
brought up could be a great driver to be
packaging and testing what is the right
price that really meets our policy the
discussion really is that the winning
you're losing getting agreement on the
most important number at the top of the
organization and then coming up with all
the categories of work with the team
this is a group discussion that they
should be able to leverage to improve
that most important number then we want
to rate how well we're leveraging those
dry drivers today to improve what's most
important and then describe what a 10
state would look like and it's not
uncommon that out on a scale from one to
ten
marketing as a driver for example the
team would say we're a one or we're a
two and I look at that and say that is
fantastic we're doing kind of okay now
and look at this opportunity to improve
over there so that's that's how you
guide the discussion what it can never
be is the leader just giving it to
everybody and saying I thought through
this the team has to come up with it
because they need to own it and what
they come up with is always better in my
experience than what any one person can
do on their own so if we look at that
example you shared with a guy who
increases prices from 60 to 85 or
whatever it was what and if you don't
know like if we had to guess or just to
give a practical example what what would
his most important number be and then
three drivers that make it up as a
solopreneur
his most important number is revenue
because it's really all coming into him
there's a little bit of cost and
materials that he would charge for on
top of the hourly rate but it's
currently Rev menu now we're having
discussions about he actually does all
the work at my my property and he's
amazing discussions about adding some
more people because he's working you
know seven days a week and he wants more
time with his family as as he should
so we're going through but revenue is at
pricing policy is still one of the in
Focus drivers I think on the commercial
side he can move it up a lot more
and then getting the right work because
all work isn't created equal customers
aren't equal
identifying and this is really marketing
but the ideal Persona clients so
marketing is a as a second driver in
there
and and now we have strategy as the
third driver
um how are we going to grow how do we
add one person two people what does that
model look like the math has to work out
I mean it's pretty scary when you start
adding employees and now all of a sudden
you're responsible for them so do we add
a full-time employee or do we add a
contractor and we only pay the
contractors when we have work so we're
never at risk so those are the top three
drivers right now that are in Focus uh
you know for this individual it's
working really well he is so happy oh my
gosh you know it's just fun to watch him
go through this and and see the see the
progress
it's it's just the kind of thing that I
mean it it's so powerful and so simple
and you feel like why didn't I think of
this or well like how come I didn't have
something in place I think a lot of
entrepreneurs we we pride ourselves on
being able to go fast and we we hate big
corporate in all the rules and
bureaucracy and like reports and
meetings and all the stuff that if we're
in big corporate now like I don't want
to build a company like that but you
kind of have to have something right and
so what I love about your thing is like
it's it's it's not just something but
something really powerful so you take
this guy if you have revenue is his most
important number and then the three
drivers of pricing marketing strategy
The Next Step so first step was like
understand what is
you know revenue and then your three
drivers and then it's what then it's
scoring yourself on those three drivers
pricing marketing strategy and then
figuring out the actions underneath to
say okay our pricing maybe was a two and
now it's an eight but maybe it could be
a ten if we fixed our our corporate
pricing and like how do we go off and do
that right so it's like the yeah the
most important number of the drivers but
then like the actions that you need to
take to start moving the numbers on
those drivers higher yeah in in this
case if the most important number is
revenue then we look at those three
drivers what's the best work that we can
do or I can do to leverage those drivers
in a way to improve that most important
number so on the pricing side I could be
packaging and testing you know different
pricing uh points out there with
commercial customers residential
customers and seeing where that sweet
spot is when uh you know looking at
competitors what are their prices
they're still all 20 to 80 percent
higher than what this guy's prices are
so there's still some room to work here
and then the strategy side what's what's
the right model so it's really thinking
about the drivers in in how we can
leverage that particular
category of work if you will to improve
what's most important and and once he
starts and gets to a place and I think
he will at some point
um if he if he chooses to add employees
the number will move from revenue to
profit because we can have we can have a
million dollars in revenue and spend a
million and a half to to get that
revenue and that doesn't work out very
well
and is that something you see
consistently when when you're working
with a solo entrepreneur focus on
Revenue to start but when you have team
go to profit or is that just the nature
of the business because he has low cost
of goods and it's just service based
that it makes sense for him
yeah for right now it makes sense for
him every business is going to be a
little bit to a lot different there are
nuances in there at the end of the day
it's about building a machine whatever
size business it is to create more and
more and more value over time so how
would we capture that so you know
revenue for a solopreneur and it's all
going into your lifestyle and you have
to set money as high for taxes and
everything that goes along with it
it's okay to start there but as you grow
it will turn into what's left over
whether it's cash flow or whether it's
profit in the non-profit world and we do
a lot of work over there and we get
amazing results as well the most
important number is always the the
primary measure of impact that nonprofit
is going to have
you know the lives impacted uh you know
kids that have access to high quality
classrooms you know whatever that
non-profit is animals saved
um and then of course they're measuring
uh you know fundraising we have to have
money to have the impact and and we may
measure 550 other things it doesn't
matter as long as those measures uh
clearly help us make better decisions to
improve our most important number if not
we're just measuring for the sake of
measuring and you said something before
about you know we don't want to run a
company like these big ones and all the
the infrastructure and you know rigid
processes and everything else
I think the problem with most operating
methodologies first I'll say that any
honest serious effort to increase or
improve the rate at which an
organization creates value I applied I
don't care what it is but when you look
at uh you know it could be it could be
EOS could be 40x could be scaling up
could be okrs there's a lot of popular
ones and thousands of less popular ones
what I notice about them is that
the people end up making the process of
going through and checking all those
boxes more important than improving
what's most important I'm super
interested in making sure we create
value in every decision every action is
through the lens of how will this
improve our most important number that's
everything in never making process more
important than what is most important
even when a star isn't in the room so
these star leaders which I think are
less than probably two percent of the
world it doesn't matter what's going on
they're going to see around corners
they're going to make adjustments
they're going to do it but when they're
not in the room okay what are we here to
do what can we do oh here's some boxes
we can check let's go do that oh the
operating system says we need to meet
for five minutes and 18 seconds on this
and then we put stuff over here and we
it's like okay we went through the
process and they lost sight of the fact
that this team should have been designed
to create value and when we come in we
create more and more and more value over
time it's it's not just about the number
it's about the whole thing and creating
value the culture of the people we want
to connect culture to financial results
we want to connect strategy to execution
all of this needs to feel amazing and be
a win-win for for everyone but that
that's really the big point I want to
make here is it can't be about process
it has to be about value creation and so
what's the number that says above all
Leathers for my team this is the value
that we're creating how is it really
driving all the right behaviors in a
shortage example there my favorite one
is is HR as companies start getting a
little bit bigger you know 50 100
employees thousands
I'll ask HR
which what do you think your most
important number is and they typically
come back with Employee Engagement or
retention that's it like we I we we just
know and they don't even have to think
very long so let's play it out if
retention is your most important number
and you have a hundred employees
and and uh if I was running it now now
it needs to be that one number plus
drive all the right behaviors in theory
two to three years out I can have 95
plus percent retention but 75 percent of
the team members can't deliver on the
the outcomes that the role requires them
to deliver on so I won on my number but
I didn't drive the right behaviors and
when when I did that it didn't improve
profitability of the company so as an
example here a better most important
number for HR would be the percentage of
seats filled with capable people and
capable as defined as they have roles
they have clear maybe one to four
outcome based responsibilities and they
are meeting those outcomes or better not
below
so that now we're driving all the right
behaviors we're helping leaders develop
their team members we're doing better
onboarding to make sure we're you know
getting the right capability Etc could
you play that out though like if a
percentage of seats with capable people
you could just have two people and
they're both great and then you never
you hit your number and you don't grow
well it depends now we've got we have
strategy so at the top level of the
organization of strategy is here and
part of the strategies we want to grow
than than all of those things are coming
into play and it would be hr's position
to just sort of build that now if you're
talking a super small company with two
people
um strategy still should be a driver and
and we should Define the roles within
the organization and what we expect the
people filling those roles to be able to
do it really is an investment we're
going to pay this and we need to get at
least a little better return on that or
that doesn't work out very well you know
across the board so the strategy decides
are we going to grow by what rate how
are we going to do that what's the
business model and then we want to make
sure that we're as as we design the
structure to accomplish that that we're
filling the roles as we grow with people
that are capable of achieving the
outcomes that we need there's this
phrase that's the most important thing
is to keep the most important thing the
most important thing
and uh I don't know who said that maybe
you do but I think as entrepreneurs we
forget what the most of it like we have
a more importantly just shiny object
shiny object what do I have to do today
what fire am I putting out and so I mean
again why I love your most important
number is like okay yeah I had like
that's the most important thing and I
have to stay focused on creating that
how often do you recommend coming back
and looking at the most important number
and the three drivers I guess one for
yourself for the entrepreneurs managing
themselves but then also for the team is
that a daily thing is that a weekly
thing a monthly thing what do you
suggest
yeah all the work that's going on
consistently every day that that the
team members are working should be
um you know in the spirit of improving
their most important number I think it's
really important for a team to meet no
less than weekly and weekly is a good
Cadence to look at where we add on our
most important number today and where
are we going in the future are we on
track at risk or behind on our most
important number as of today and then
what's the best work we can do to get it
back on track or improve it even if
we're ahead of plan but weekly it's a
really good Cadence and and I would
think about it um in in three ways it's
alignment it's decisions and it's
accountability so it's alignment around
all the things that we can do as a team
to improve what's most important and
then it's decisions around doing the
right work at the right time in the
right order given a hundred things we
could do what are the right three to do
next that will create the most value
given where we're at and then the
accountability piece just holding each
other accountable to do what we said we
would when we said we would and so this
weekly Cadence is is really important
and I've seen some where man
everything's going great let's just move
it to monthly and then they start
drifting all over the place you know and
and so maybe the meetings initially
could be as long as two hours to really
get that alignment make better decisions
and and drive accountability not
uncommon that even with a team of 12 on
a senior leadership team that we're down
to 30 to 45 minutes max but it's
important to keep that alignment and
it's always surprising to me
you know it shouldn't be anymore but but
senior teams weren't in in full
alignment or agreement on what that most
important number should be until they
started going through this process and I
think that's really common for a founder
of an organization of any size uh to
think hey it's it's in my head I totally
get it of course everybody else
understands and
um they they just don't so we have to
keep this alignment process going and
you know one thing I've learned through
this whole process is to never
underestimate people's ability to not
connect the dots it's just it's it just
it's not a a muscle that most develop uh
the Mind methodology gets them to
develop that over time and really
improve their decision-making muscles as
well again back to the Simplicity of it
I remember I was stressed out looking at
all the different I don't do you call it
operational system does that is that
fair or what do you call even what you
do
I well I call it the Mind methodology
and that's how we that's how we call it
it's it's how an organization operates
to create value so you want to call it a
business management operating system an
organizational operating system uh it's
you know it it's really strange how
people think about this and and the
value they assign to it and I look at it
and and say well who would be our
competition then our competition is any
honest effort within any organization of
any size to accelerate the rate at which
they create value and most of our
competition is homegrown it's coming up
with their own stuff and doing it and I
love organizations like um you know
scaling up or EOS and you know they're
um all the folks out there pushing okrs
uh I love that because they're they're
making
um an intentional operating system a
thing like you should do this
and and every organization should be
really intentional about creating more
value and and uh and so in doing that
you can pick from a wide variety of
these systems that are out there
um my challenge with virtually all of
them uh two things one they make process
more important what is most important
but also almost all of them are based on
traditional goal setting and traditional
goal setting does not stand the test of
time it just doesn't for so many reasons
and we've solved for that with a mind
methodology
and you know to Simply state it
Simplicity wins I don't care if you have
one team 10 teams hundreds and hundreds
of teams
every team has a most important number
categories of work or drivers that
they're leveraging to improve it we can
see how they're meeting the decisions
they're making and are they doing what
they said they would and all this bolts
perfectly together doesn't matter how
many teams and you also know that when
you improve your most important number
it'll improve the next one up all the
way to the top of the organization I
used to call this team out because you
can start with any team get amazing
results and just go out directionally
you know in any company of any size over
there but Simplicity wins you mentioned
some of your your competition and I
looked at them before getting connected
to you and I mean you were very kind and
generous towards them I wouldn't be as
so but uh in in looking through their
books and their methodology I quickly
got stressed out and overwhelmed like oh
my God it's like a it's a giant 25 part
form for any decision that you're trying
to make and yeah I looked at it okay
when I told myself before talking to Joe
and getting connected to you what I told
myself was okay this is just a part of
getting bigger
and I'm gonna have to suck it up I'm
gonna have to do it and that's just what
companies do right otherwise I stay
stuck at 30 people or whatever I was at
at the time
um and then finding your system like oh
I don't have to fill out all those forms
this is great we can get a lot more work
done instead of just sitting there
writing out forms and forms and forms
um so you talk about traditional goal
setting not working in in companies or
entrepreneur organizations like why is
it broken why doesn't it work think
about what it feels like so you know
within your organization or anybody
watching this podcast
um yeah it there's a lot of different
approaches to goal setting but you know
Common would be every quarter come up
with you know one to three goals that
you come up with get it approved by your
manager and then rinse and repeat every
single quarter and on paper this could
be amazing but what works on paper and
in our heads doesn't necessarily work in
the real world what does it feel like
for all the employees to go through that
process super stressful most of them
don't even really understand since they
don't have a most important number
they're just putting down goals that
they can actually do they don't
understand this concept of value
creation and and we should be designed
as a team to actually do that and it
just feels terrible and and when I when
I go into a new company and I'll I'll
say hey let me look at all the goals
that are going on and there could be 10
employees or hundreds or but I look at
the goals and usually 95 percent of them
are just not very thoughtful they're
terrible they're terrible and the
employees hate the process now you shift
it over to the Mind methodology
um here's a team I'm on a team I was
part of the discussion coming up with
our most important number for the
discussion coming up with the categories
of work that we can leverage we decide I
did here's where our number today let's
say it's gross profit and I work in a
you know making the product for this
particular company with the team doing
it it's gross profit and we are
currently at 35 and our goal by the end
of next year is to be at 46 and so every
month we're doing things to continually
improve gross profit now every decision
every action we're coming in we're
assigning it appropriately to team
members we got one number that says
we're winning or losing this is the work
I'm doing to improve it I was hired in
this role and here's the couple of
outcomes that I need to achieve to help
support improving that most important
number now it's Evergreen and it's
incredibly easy and simple it should
never be in my opinion opinion what you
said earlier around I guess this is just
part of growing and you have to do this
stuff it should feel amazing it should
feel amazing and you know when it's
really working you know it's not and
traditional goal setting uh for the
reason I just stated or the reasons I
just stay stated and many more it it
never stands the test of time but if you
get the most important numbers right the
ultimate goal for the team is going to
be their forecast for where they're
going to be on that most important
number over time
and then keep it all in Balance we have
marketing we have sales we have
operations customer service we have
Finance we have HR we have all this
stuff as one goes up the others better
keep up I call it the organizational
structure bottleneck game because one
function in any organization
at any point in time will be holding it
back from creating the value that's
possible more than all the others and so
we're just running around and Shoring
stuff up and keeping everything in
Balance one balloon way above the others
can take us out of the game one way
below all the others can take us out of
the game
um so that that's why I don't I don't
think it stands the test of time and
then you you touched on something else
that
um has been super frustrating for at
least early for me for a lot of years
and that's we would hear from all the
experts oh if you want to do strategy
better if you want to improve culture
better if you want to handle supply
chain or marketing or sales here's my
one page
um thinking tool if you will
and and you're you're welcome to take
this and and deploy it in your company
well how do you operationalize 400
pieces of paper and different ways of
looking at stuff that the complexity
that comes with it it's almost
impossible to do I've never seen anybody
do it but the complexity that comes with
it is there's not much you can do with
it really and and now when you go over
the Mind methodology every team having
their their men and doing the best work
they can do to improve it and
everybody's thinking about value
creation the same way and it works so
the goal setting doesn't work all of
these stacks of ways to do things from
all the experts on the planet how do you
operationalize it it stresses me out too
that's the first place I go oh look at
this great idea I'm just going okay well
how how would we actually do that you
know at scale inside a company but how
does that resonate with you Evan I agree
I love it it is it is fun you know it's
like surprisingly fun and awesome to go
through uh and it also really the huge
burden and stress of me feeling like
well I have to go through this process
and that's just part of getting bigger
in all honesty when I was looking when I
asked Joe when we when we ended up
connecting I was looking at you more for
something from my wife than for me
because I felt like I'm great at what I
do and I'm managing like my 10 to 12
people but like she was struggling in
managing the team I would say like I do
I run the Navy Seals and she runs the
Navy and and I'm like short fast type
projects in and out like let's kick
things off but then she needs to
operationalize all of the crazy stuff
that I come up with and she didn't have
a system to do it so like okay well we
need and she never trained for this she
didn't go to school she didn't she
didn't know Lee Benson growing up you
know she she just kind of went with it
and so at the starting point was I need
something to give Nina so she can run
the Navy and not feel stressed out but
in going through the process of finding
you know my most important number uh
it's like oh I can use this too like
this is great for me as well and it is
fun and not just something that that's
for the team so you said once a week we
should be checking in off with ourselves
but also with team on on the number and
the drivers and the actions underneath
how often does it change how often
should we even be
thinking about if our our most important
number or the driver should change if we
go back to your first example the guy is
going to hiring people now okay well now
we need to eliminate Revenue so our our
most important number completely shifts
um maybe at some point you got the
pricing dialed in so we gotta eliminate
that like how do we start to know when
either the most important number or the
three things underneath need to change
yeah great question usually with early
stage companies the most important
number will evolve into what it's
ultimately going to be and the most
important number for an established
business rarely changes once you really
get it right in an example of an early
stage company we have a couple of
startups that we're invested in they're
etw clients they're using the Mind
methodology and the the first most
important number was getting to Beta
launch and so it was a launch date and
burning down of everything we need to do
to get there now we're in the middle of
that and the next most important number
is the public launch and all the stuff
that has to happen to go in there so
we've got we have marketing and reach
Readiness that's you know building up
this machine and ready to go we have the
the beta client experience team you know
iterating you know very quickly on
what's working what isn't and then
interfacing with the dev team to
incorporate that in the app but then
once it once it goes it will evolve into
reach so how many users on the platform
but eventually it will drive towards
profitability or the valuation of the
organization before an exit there's
always an evolution in an early stage
company and then the drivers they really
never go away but they can evolve like
refine what you call them you can add
additional ones you might remove one
occasionally that didn't really make
sense but what I think is important if
we end up with a set of 10 drivers that
are categories of work that we can
leverage to improve our most important
number there's usually never more than
three that are really in focus at any
point in time and we've all heard it you
can't improve everything all at once but
the two or three that are in Focus if we
really move the needle there without
letting any of the others collect dust
or go backwards
that'll create more value faster than
focusing on some of the others so they
just move around so pricing is something
as an example you brought it you know
back to the front here a couple of times
it really never goes away competition is
coming and going and all kinds of things
are changing and inflation and all of
this we can't ignore that and we should
always be charging the right perfect
price around what the market will
actually pay for right you know given
given supply and demand and perceive
value out there so drivers change a lot
men's once they're established or you're
established as a company probably won't
change yeah so I mean going back to that
guy again it's a great example because
he's a solo guy who's now applied your
methodology and I was growing like crazy
and now building a team or that becomes
the next step so if his drivers move
from revenue sorry if it's Min the most
important number move some Revenue to
profitability uh if he's hiring a team
maybe one of the three drivers need to
be something related to team and
Leadership and growth and managing
people as opposed to just making about
marketing pricing and strategy yeah I
would I would add next actually we have
thought about you know job Readiness and
we're looking at his vehicle and how
it's all set up I just love doing this I
would coach people if I had to sleep I
do it all night because it's just so
much fun you know creating value in the
world we would look at
um you know job Readiness so when you go
out to do a job or all the parts there
you're not making five or six extra
trips and then there would be training
and development we want people to get up
to speed you know very very quickly and
there are a couple of candidates that
would be great to bring on board for
this for this gentleman the other
interesting thing that was surprising
for me that I didn't expect there wasn't
asking for but then ended up being a
huge win was a meeting structure and I I
on the airplane ride home as I'm reading
your book I I wrote to the people that I
meet every week and just completely
changed how we run our meetings where it
went from an hour to 25 minutes so
everybody now got like basically half
the time a little less than half the
time of my time every week uh you lead
with a win so like what is the win of
the week what are we celebrating what
are we cheering on and these are still
just one-on-one meetings this isn't me
meeting like five people but the
structure still applies so the first
five minutes is the win that you want to
share
um they have to come up with uh the the
most important number of the drivers and
then we talk about it together which is
already helps Focus the meetings a lot
more and then they have to bring an
agenda so it's not just show up and say
okay what's up what's on your mind how
can I help and so with them bringing the
agenda every week with them updating
their men and their drivers every week
with them sharing their win every week
we get more done in 25 minutes like it's
probably three to four times as
effective in 25 minutes then the hour
that I was taking every week meeting
with everybody yeah and that is not
unusual at all and and what are these
team members saying now that you've gone
through this for a while what what's
you're getting more done and that's
completely normal but what are they
saying is it helping their Clarity and
ability to create value effect what's
going on with them yeah yeah that's a
great question so and honestly how we
did it was I took Drew who was one guy
that I met with every week he's the most
open to like he loves new things he
loves breaking things apart like if it's
not if it's not great it's fine like he
loves nitpicking he's an engineer by
trade like he loves all this kind of
stuff so I started with him so Drew we
got to start with this and uh I worked
out my Kinks because I wasn't an expert
yet on this I'm still trying to figure
it out as we go like I just read this
book I'm not an expert but I'm trying to
take what's in here and we made it work
for him and uh then after June we
applied it to everybody because there
was still some work to do was like what
is because it's it's the most important
number for the org but then everybody
has their own most important number too
which is incredibly powerful but also
not something we had done at all for
anybody so it's like okay Drew come up
with your most important number and then
what are the three drivers that go
underneath and so as a coaching process
to figure that out the first time fun uh
invigorating but like if you come up
with 10 different things no no you got
to focus through not 10 things three
things what are the three drivers that's
it you had to pick three that was a
mentorship exercise for me that then
once we nailed it in for Jew it got
applied to everybody else and and they
love it you know I mean I think at first
everybody's a little sad to lose half
the time
because they like the one-on-one
sessions but it allowed me to bring on
two more people that now that I meet
every week and people are a lot more
productive they know where every meeting
is going they forces them to do a little
bit of homework before coming to the
meeting that is obviously saves me a lot
of time but saves them time as well and
it's only been positive like everybody
loves the system which is great I think
there was a little concern at the
beginning too like oh no what's the
system that is going to introduce us to
because some people come from corporate
and and we have not been typically
corporates like but just try it and they
love it
um so yeah I'm huge huge fan I mean
that's why I got so excited I I'm
genuinely it's like one of the best
books that I've read
this year and had a huge impact on on
growing my business yeah thank you and
and that's one of the challenges there's
so many people out there saying if you
do this system or do that everything
will be amazing so how do you believe
the next one and you know that could be
part of what how this lands on folks
that are that are watching the podcast
and and you know to get through that
what we end up doing is if we want to
start engaging with a client uh I love
it when solopreneurs read the book and
they start changing the language and the
results start getting better it's
fantastic and they're they're doing it
on their own their investment as just
the book which is which is virtually
nothing but when we start with a client
you know we'll actually go out and do
the work and and we'll do their work
with our methodology we'll be with them
for a year but before we engage anybody
we do a two-hour experience no cost no
obligation bring your team in and
they'll always have what kind of
homework we need to be ready and no you
don't have to do anything to get ready
for this we're going to guide the whole
thing and over the course of two hours
uh we we decide or sort of get more
agreement or alignment on what winning
looks like over the next couple years
what the most important number is a
couple of other key measures to make
decisions to improve that number what
the main driver should be and we'll dig
into one of them and we come out the end
of two hours and you know ask everybody
hey what's your biggest takeaway from
going through this two-hour session
and
almost a hundred percent of the time wow
we're more aligned
um I didn't realize this was our most
important number I didn't see the bigger
picture in the organization I've been
kind of living in my Silo and we want to
do that for two hours to make sure it's
a good cultural fit for the company and
for us as a client because if it's not
right either way it's it's just not
going to be a good experience coming out
the other side and most of the time it's
a good cultural fit the few times that
it's not is it's almost always where the
leader of the founder just isn't willing
to be transparent so if if profit's the
most important number and the founder or
CEO or president isn't willing to share
that number for fear of I'm not sure
what in all of my companies by the way
and I'm on the seventh one I've started
from scratch everybody gets to see
everything even when I had 500 plus
employees in one Aerospace company
everybody got all the books if they
wanted it and and if they didn't
understand uh you know Financial
language debit credit you know things
like that we gave them a plain English
version of it so they so they could see
so many rolls of tape and this and this
is what it cost and it was amazing when
they saw that the decisions they made to
reduce costs it was incredible
um but yeah it's uh
Simplicity wins I'll just I'll sum it up
with that you hopped on a two-hour call
we did that call was me you ali uh on
your team and then Nina and my team and
that was amazing like the two hours flew
by and yes some deep questions
that forced us to think which is great
because I think a lot of times we're
just so in the operations of the
business and doing and and kind of
forget where we're going what we're
trying to create just put my YouTube hat
on for a second if you ever want to
create content that is fantastic content
to dive into people's businesses and
record it if they're willing to then
turn into videos I think you can help a
lot of people through that process how
do you integrate
learning into this so
um one of the things that for for Nina
my wife so she's working with people on
the team and now everybody who comes on
they have to figure out their most
important number together and then what
are the three drivers and Nina is not
the expert on a lot of things like how
do we grow on LinkedIn okay Nina's not
not the LinkedIn expert but she's
managing the person who's running our
LinkedIn so you know the most important
number is is LinkedIn related growth
like we want to have X number of
followers that's our most important
number for that person right uh and then
drivers underneath would be related to
how well the content is doing and the
frequency of the content Etc but then
the third one that we've done is always
some kind of learning where okay what
did you learn this past week and she
meets them every week what did you learn
this past week and how are you applying
it and the learning might be watching a
YouTube video doing a skillshare course
um not so much reading the book for
LinkedIn but looking at what other
people are doing on LinkedIn and trying
to trying to learn from them and they
have to report back every week to see
like what did you learn and what are we
trying and did it work or not and in
doing that it alleviated Nina's burden
of her feeling like she had to be the
expert on the thing because it's
impossible for her to be expert on
LinkedIn and Twitter and Instagram and
uh everybody else that she's managing
yeah and so we just kind of adapted that
I'm curious so how to for somebody who's
managing
other people and you're doing the weekly
meetings
how do they incorporate learning into
the process do people often make it as
one of the drivers is that one of the
actions underneath what are people doing
yeah it's a top level for an
organization uh Team Member development
should be a driver what's our approach
to doing it one of the things that I
really love the most about the Mind
methodology is how you can more
intentionally surgically develop every
single team member you know especially
leaders I mean I I think we make a lot
of a lot of mistakes out there billions
and billions spent on leadership
development in the United States alone
and and they keep putting leaders
through one size fits all leadership
development and back to what I said
earlier I never underestimate people's
ability to never connect the dots it
comes back and they typically don't
apply it and even they did kind of apply
it there's no systemic way of doing it
in the organization because they don't
have something like the Mind methodology
and so when it comes to development if
I'm on a team whether I'm leading it or
I'm I'm the only team member in in your
case and a lot of other small companies
with your reports
um but I'm on this team here's the most
important number here's our forecast for
it and we need to stay at or above that
to be in balance with the rest of the
organization to create the value that we
want to create now we start falling
below what's causing us to fall below
and so even if you're not an expert it
points you to where you need to get help
and you know kind of like what Dan
Sullivan says which I love you know who
not how it points you uh to to where you
need to go get help so if if we want to
increase subscribers on YouTube and
we're we're below plan well why are we
below plan we have that discussion well
because we we're not doing this or we
don't have capability here our
competitors are making these moves all
right well what can we do and we make
the list of what we we can do or what we
should do to improve it we either have
the capability or we don't but now we
can surgically develop the leader and
the team members
um based on what's happening with our
results and even if we're beating the
number the most important number how do
we accelerate it even more what
capability or you know team members that
we need to add or anything else to
increase it now we're surgically
developing because when you when you
evaluate a leader
hey they're really strong in these three
categories they're weak in these two
categories well maybe the thing they
need to develop on is to increase the
strength because that will be what moves
the most important number over anything
else so from a development standpoint
whether you're a leader or a
non-supervisory uh you know team member
um when you're when you're looking at
their results it always shows you
exactly where they need to develop next
last question I want to know why you
care so much I've seen a lot of
entrepreneurs who they hit three four or
five hundred thousand dollars a year in
income into like I'm good you know like
they take the foot way off the gas and
they're just kind of coasting making
good money getting their house getting
their car
um it's it's rare for a lot of
Consultants even to get a million
dollars not that they're not capable
it's just I'm good I'm good by myself
just teaching this stuff you're a guy
who sold this business for like 300
million dollars and have a gorgeous
house and you know taking me around and
like and you're still here aggressively
working and building and creating and
the energy is still there and the
passion is still there
why do you care so much about this Lee
all right foundationally I think the
answer to all the problems in the United
States and and you know most likely the
rest of the world
um all these challenges all these things
going on would be solved if we had
really strong healthy communities the
stronger a community they have each
other's backs especially in bad times
and they need less and less outside
intervention or help at all and I I
really saw this happening in in the
largest company of the seven that had
over 500 employees as we were growing up
through the years I had dozens of
spouses come to me and say hey my
husband or wife is a better person to
live with after less than a year of
working at your company what are you
doing and so I'm watching
um you know the this this winning sort
of environment it's fun to accomplish
challenging things because because
everybody knows all the numbers and how
they create value they're all acting
like CEOs of their own roles people come
through on tour and I everybody looks
you in the eye they shake your hand they
know the numbers and then they're blown
away that I can walk around and I know
all their numbers too and can have these
conversations so that permeates out into
families into communities
um and I watch the strength of our
community at the organization
um every weekend there's dozens of
barbecues that you're invited to I mean
stuff's going on all the time it's just
incredible what's happening employees
went through over the years you know it
just happens unfortunately you know
given the numbers through different
really unfortunate circumstances and I
just you don't have to do anything
everybody surrounds them and makes it
better it's incredible
and so the these team members understood
the power of making their primary
identity the value that they create in
the world it's like well you know what
what if we could get this into a million
different organizations and have that
going out it's it's I always say when I
talk to kids you're going to be running
the world I retire in someday and I want
it to be amazing that's some burnt down
dystopian future
and and so I I lean in here because I
think it makes a giant difference with
for-profit and non-profits I also lean
in with K-12 education in Arizona and
I'm not affiliated with any political
party I'm not happy with any of them
actually because they seem to be
fighting over money and in the case of
K-12 students it's not about the kids
it's about adults getting money so I'm
not not for any of that
I'm all about the kids and I I have this
this vision of wouldn't it be amazing if
we could launch graduated seniors out of
high school they can think critically so
they don't fall for all this stuff
that's going on the primary value their
identity their primary identity value is
is the value they create in the world
they're financially literate and as
independent as they choose to be I was
on my own before I left high school and
it was a non-event it was it was great
and and we and they understand that
struggle is good you know I'm co-writing
a book right now uh with Scott Donald
one of the founders of gravy stack and
the subtitle is the struggles your kids
need to succeed we're trying to take all
that away and now we're trying to take
it away from adults if we don't struggle
we don't grow and and why they're trying
to do that I I don't really know but
that's what I want I want these kids
getting launched that are productive you
know community members everything they
do is about creating better conditions
to work live learn and play I think
that's the answer to all the problems in
the world and if we don't go all the way
Upstream you know in that in even in the
home before kindergarten start working
on this it's a losing game that's
happening out there right now so that's
probably a longer answer than you wanted
but that that's why I do this and I
could literally talk about this for days
I love it man well the man is Lee Benson
the book is your most important number
we'll link it up down in the description
below go check it out Lee thank you for
your time your wisdom your energy and
for giving me one of my favorite books
of the year thank you Evan I always
enjoy our conversations really
appreciate you just